Over the last 52 weeks I've enjoyed sharing
with you my fascination with biology.
If you've been through it with us, you've
now got yourself now a pretty deep and complex
understanding of how life functions, from
the chemistry that makes cells work to the
ecosystems that make the planet work.
And it's never too late to catch up on those
biology and ecology courses; they'll be here
on Youtube forever.
But it's time to move onto something new.
Something bigger because it's smaller, more
beautiful because it's invisible, more powerful
because it's everything.
Crash Course Chemistry.
My undergraduate degree is actually in chemistry,
and I've been a lifelong lover of this subject,
not just the rules, and laws, and the bonds,
and the coefficients.
But of the men and women who shaped this science
that deepened our understanding of the world
so magnificently.
The Siberian misanthrope who would revolution
our understanding of matter.
The German war criminal who saved a billion
lives.
The French aristocrat who created the science
of chemistry and all he got for his trouble
was beheaded.
And of course all of these stories exist within
the greatest science ever.
What is matter made of?
How and when do atoms come together and break
apart?
What is an electron?
Why is silver's chemical symbol Ag?
How do we fix global warming and live forever?
The answers to all of these questions (except
for the last two) will be contained within
this course.
But those last two, if and when they get solved
I guarantee you will be solved with the help
of chemistry.
And we'll be doing it in this beautiful new
set that was designed and created by Nick
Jenkins.
And our graphics team, our graphics team,
will be 'Thought Cafe'.
Which is what 'Thought Bubble' has turned
into.
We're slaving away on Crash Course Chemistry
now and the first episode should be hitting
your subscription box within the next couple
of weeks.
Until then, feel free to check out any of
the biology that you may have missed, and
we'll see you soon.